[Music]
i think that your friend hannah is
really sexy
oh my god you did not just say that
how old are you what are you lawyer
yeah a little bit come on i know you
want is she
gonna be don't you think you're a little
old to be using cheesy pick-up lines
objection leading the witness
wow hannah you're really wearing that
dress like you're doing it a favor oh
god
that's a line with me sitting over there
for the past two hours not being able to
take my eyes off of you
is a fact i find you very attractive
do you find me attractive she does i
don't
you do she does yes she does i i don't
permission to approach
the bench seriously just come on let me
let me deliver my closing argument sure
proceed
anna we live in a physical world right
uh-huh
and you're going to age right
i guarantee you this you're never going
to regret going home with that guy from
the bar that one time that was a total
tomcat in the sack
but i can't guarantee that you won't not
regret it that's a double negative
you're a double negative no ring
no red what no but inside that box
underneath all that crap there was a
little handwritten note
with the address to a hotel date
in time real humphrey bogart type stuff
masculine anyway naturally margaret
i thought he was seeing someone else
yeah it was a terrible time for me but
i went to that hotel anyway i went there
and i pounded on the door but the door
was already unlocked
and as i swung open that door
there he was standing kneeling like a
man on a bed of rose petals in a tuxedo
your son your son and he was choking
back
soft soft sobs and when he held back the
tears and finally caught his breath
he said to me margaret will you marry me
and she said yep in the end
who's hungry sorry i can help you with
that
that's right stay there yay you too
touch your fingers
lift it up oh everybody okay
so i just need 30 seconds with this
woman
thank you oh coming through sorry
i know this is a far throw from a hidden
paradise
but wherever you are in the world that's
where i belong
but i
rachel true
will you marry me
and make me the happiest man in this
world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
um oh
i love hawaii yeah
it's nice but i think for like a week
tops
any more than that i know i'd go crazy
because i think that
hawaii is a place to escape for people
who can't deal with the real world
yeah you know there's so few personal
shoppers and pet therapists
gosh it's such a hard life
i like living here
there's something wrong with me you know
i'm too trusting i've done a dark alley
again with a complete stranger i don't
even
start here
all right then no
i'm fine you're fine that's a poetry
emotion it's off come on
sure i never want to kiss anyway
okay now i am intrigued how are you
going to dispose of my body
i am shane
are you seriously doing a james bond
impression now's not the time to
unpleasantness
now is the time for romance
you like all right
let's go all right it was senior year
during finals
the year-end issue was off to the
printer and the staff had left for the
night
we both had studying to do but we were
mad tired
only stevie wonder was going to help us
that night
[Music]
is
[Music]
and i'll be loving you always
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
since the beginning and the seasons know
exactly when to change
just as kindness knows no shame i'm
looking for your joy and pain
but i'll be loving you always
you can't make the right decisions you
tried all the wrong ones at least i
fight for what i want
oh what do you want melanie i don't even
think you know
you're the first boy i ever kissed jake
and i want you to be the last
maybe you and i had our chance
[Music]
come on have it your way you stubborn
ass
[Music]
what you wanna be married to me for
anyhow
so i can kiss you anytime i want
you should bless me for destroying him
before he found out what you really
are and what am i faithfulness he talked
of madam your enduring faithfulness now
tell me truly when you found out he was
gone did you get engaged to your prince
at same hour did you wait a whole week
out of respect for the dead
you mocked me once never do it again i
died that day
you can die too for all i can't oh
ah
oh my sweet wesley what have i done
it's you it's me
but that night at the party yeah i was
uh i was drunk
and confused and it ended like a minute
after you your size
[Music]
and you're jewish yeah
which is cool and i'm black too
and gay it's kind of crazy huh
i didn't think you'd come me neither
until i was walking towards you i i
didn't think i had it in me
[Music]
[Music]
are you disappointed that it's me
no
[Music]
do it look okay uh hmm
something's missing well
nothing else is gonna fit into this
dress i'll tell you that maybe something
in this box
i don't want you to get too excited it's
only on loan
[Laughter]
they really let you borrow this from the
jewelry store i'm a very good customer
if you were gonna buy this how much
would it cost a quarter of a million
a quarter of a million dollars i have
been waiting half my life for you to
wake up and love me
having loved you for half a lifetime i
realized when you left that i had made a
bad choice doing that
and now it's got even trickier because
when you were playing in pubs we were
the perfect match but now
i'm an actual school teacher in actual
low stuff and you're the
world's greatest singer songwriter i'm
not except you probably
are okay two minutes ladies and
gentlemen for two minutes
also um deborah's on my phone for you
apparently she's having dinner with the
head of the label and you're meant to be
facetiming
just go out rookie uh okay one minute
53. in the end to you
i'll always really just be ellie with
the frizzy hair
[Music]
eddie from the fun chum column ellie who
for reasons no one understands drives
you around
in her car so just go and please just
catch a plane
[Music]
[Music]
what the hell's that fruit doing here
get out of the way excuse me sir i have
to start the beverages how you doing sir
chicken or fish you better get out of my
way billy you're gonna get hurt oh yeah
don't you talk to billy idol that
[Music]
the dishes way our kitchen sink
put you to bed when you've had too much
to drink
could be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you